(Risas) (Aplausos)
Y tenemos los pies más grandes para estar lejos del lavadero de la cocina.
(Risas)
Compartiré con Uds. 2 secretos del éxito:
Rodéense de personas de primera, y personas que les gustan;
y elijan a sus parejas con mucha atención.
Porque el otro día cuando dije: "Mi marido es un ángel",
una mujer se quejó: "Tienes suerte", dijo,
"el mío todavía está vivo".
(Risas)
Si el éxito fuera fácil, todos seríamos millonarios.
Pero en mi caso, vino en medio de trauma familiar y, de hecho, de crisis.
Nuestro difunto hijo, Giles, era hijo único, un bebé hermoso y feliz.
Y luego, a los 2 años y medio,
como un niño cambiado en un cuento de hadas,
perdió lo poco que hablaba
y se convirtió en un niño salvaje, ingobernable.
No eran "los terribles 2 años";
era profundamente autista y nunca volvió a hablar.
Giles fue el primer residente de la primera casa de caridad que creé,
pionera en servicios para el autismo.
Y luego fue una escuela innovadora en Prior's Court
para alumnos con autismo,
y una organización benéfica de investigación médica para el autismo.
Porque cada vez que encontré un hueco en los servicios, traté de ayudar.
Me gusta hacer cosas nuevas y hacer que ocurran cosas nuevas.
Creé una usina de pensamiento de 3 años para autismo.
Algo de mi riqueza vuelve a la industria que la forjó,
también fundé el Oxford Internet Institute
y otras empresas de TI.
El Oxford Internet Institute no solo hace hincapié en la tecnología,
sino en el aspecto social, económico, jurídico y ético de Internet.
Giles murió inesperadamente hace 17 años.
He aprendido a vivir sin él,
y he aprendido a vivir sin su necesidad de mí.
Ahora solo hago filantropía.
No me preocupa perderme
porque varias organizaciones benéficas vendrían rápidamente al rescate.
(Risas)
Una cosa es tener una idea para crear una empresa,
pero como sabrán muchos en esta sala,
hacer que suceda es algo muy difícil
y requiere una energía extraordinaria, confianza en uno mismo y determinación,
el valor para arriesgar familia y hogar,
y un compromiso 24/7 que raya en la obsesión.
Es justo decir también que soy adicta al trabajo.
Creo en la belleza del trabajo cuando se hace correctamente y con humildad.
El trabajo no es algo que hago cuando preferiría estar haciendo otra cosa.
Vivimos la vida hacia adelante.
¿Qué me enseñó todo esto?
Me enseñó que el mañana nunca será como hoy,
y ciertamente tampoco como ayer.
Eso me hizo enfrentar el cambio,
y, de hecho, con el tiempo, dar la bienvenida al cambio,
aunque me han dicho que sigo siendo muy difícil.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)